- All right. Well, welcome
everyone for coming out
for our 2022 spring Chubb
Fellowship with Hilary Hahn.
(audience applauding)
So, I can't say enough how
much of an honor this is
to be up here introducing
Hilary Hahn to all of you.
It's just been quite the journey
in terms of getting her here,
and now the day has come.
So it is really, really
thrilling to have three-time
Grammy Award winning violin
virtuoso, Hilary Hahn with us.
So before we begin today's conversation,
I ask that you make sure you
turn off all your cell phones
and refrain from taking any photographs,
except for our official photographer,
so that you don't disrupt today's program.
And please don't record either, okay?
So, devices off.
And I wanna begin today's program
with a land acknowledgement.
Today's Chubb Fellowship event sits on
traditional indigenous territories.
This includes lands of
the Mohegan, Mahican,
Mashantucket Pequot, Eastern
Pequot, Schaghticoke,
Golden Hill Paugussett,
Niantic, Quinnipiac
and other Algonquin speaking peoples.
We honor and pay respect to their peoples
of past and present.
So, my name is Mary Lui.
I'm a professor in the
Department of History
and the program of American Studies,
and also affiliated with
ethnicity, race and migration.
I'm also the head of
Timothy Dwight College,
the home of the Chubb Fellowship.
So as the head of Timothy Dwight, or TD,
I have the honor of serving as a custodian
of our illustrious Chubb
Fellowship established in 1941
out of a prior large donation
for education purposes.
This was made in 1936 by Hendon Chubb,
a graduate of the Yale class of 1895.
Since its establishment,
the Chubb fund has adhered
to the goals of providing
encouragement and aid to students
interested in government
and American public affairs.
The fellowship, initially aimed to foster
among our Yale undergraduates
an interest in public service
and local and state
affairs, grew over the years
to include numerous distinguished
visitors in national
and international affairs, as
well as leaders in the world
of the arts and humanities.
Since the 1940s, the Chubb
Fellowship lecture series
has inspired generations of Yale students
to undertake public service
and pursue leadership roles
in the hopes of creating
a better world today
and for posterity.
The fellowship has hosted
four US presidents,
George H.W. Bush, Gerald
Ford, Jimmy Carter
and Harry Truman.
And in recent years, we've
welcomed a wide range
of national and international leaders,
including our congressional
representative,
the Honorable Rosa DeLauro,
Olympic ice skater, Michelle Kwan,
visual artist, Faith Ringgold,
environmental activist, Bill McKibben,
physician and humanitarian, Dr. Hawa Abdi
and world renowned actor, Shah Rukh Khan,
just to name a few.
So with this quick description
of the history and aims
of the Chubb Fellowship,
I'm deeply honored today
to have Hilary Hahn
join the impressive list of Chubb fellows
who have visited Timothy
Dwight college and Yale.
And today's event has
particularly deep significance
as it marks the relaunch of
our Chubb Fellowship program
after a two-year disruption,
because of the COVID 19 pandemic.
TD had selected Ms. Hahn to
be our fall 2020 Chubb fellow
just before the university shut
down in the spring of 2020.
And we have waited
patiently for two years,
and I heard that she's waited
patiently for two years
to come to campus and
join us in restarting
our wonderful Chubb Fellowship.
We've always considered
the Chubb as our gift
to the university and to
the city of New Haven.
So for today's Chubb event,
I'm particularly grateful
for the hard work
of my wonderful Timothy
Dwight College staff,
our student aids team, the
support of Yale College Arts,
the School of Music, and
the Yale Symphony Orchestra
for supporting our spring
Chubb Fellowship Program.
Putting together a large scale
public event is never simple.
And doing so under COVID 19 conditions,
is even more challenging.
So, thank you to everyone who
helped make this happen today.
I'm just simply thrilled
that we're once again
able to share the Chubb
Fellowship with the university
and the city.
So with that, let me
get to our main event.
So as a preschooler, Hilary
Hahn started her musical studies
with the Suzuki method violin lessons
at the Peabody Conservatory in Baltimore.
At the age of 10, she was admitted
to the Curtis Institute
of Music in Philadelphia.
So all you people who
are just starting violin,
you gotta get a move on it.
(audience laughing)
At 17, she recorded her debut album
"Hilary Hahn plays Bach" to wide acclaim.
And in 2001, she was named America's best
young classical musician by Time Magazine.
She has recorded with Decca,
Deutsche Grammophon and Sony.
And her 19 feature albums
have all opened on the top 10
of the Billboard charts.
She has won Grammys for
three of her albums,
the 2003 Brahms and
Stravinsky Concerto album,
a 2008 pairing of the Schoenberg
and Sibelius Concerti,
and her 2013 recording of In 27 Pieces,
the Hilary Hahn Encores.
Hilary Hahn is a great
supporter of new music.
In 2009, she premiered
composer Jennifer Higdon's
violin concerto that
had been written for her
when the two first met in Higdon's class
in 20th Century music at Curtis.
She premiered the Higdon Concerto
with the Indianapolis Symphony Orchestra,
and the piece was awarded
the Pulitzer Prize
the following year.
In addition to Higdon, she
has collaborated with a number
of contemporary composers,
commissioning new works
such as Six Partidas by Anton Garcia Abril
and Sonata number four, Fractured
Dreams by Lera Auerbach.
Timothy Dwight College selected
Ms. Hahn to be our fall 2020
Chubb fellow in recognition
of her leadership in making
music accessible through her
performances and recordings.
She has launched several exciting projects
such as her #100daysofpractice,
which we'll hear more about,
using the Instagram platform
to inspire musicians
of all levels to play and
share in their experience
of music making.
She's also launched the
"Bring Your Own Baby" concerts
to encourage parents
of infants and toddlers
to share their love of classical music
in relaxed and welcoming environment.
And in 2014, Hahn was awarded
the Glashutte Original
Music Festival Award
for her "ability to inspire young people"
through the intensive and
a compromising approach
to making music.
In 2019, she donated her $25,000 prize
to the Philadelphia nonprofit,
Project 440, in recognition
of their outstanding work with
the city's youth to ignite
their interest in music and
harness music's potential
for individual growth and
community empowerment.
For those reasons, she is
our spring 2020 Chubb fellow.
So, her energetic and innovative
leadership in expanding
the world of classical
music is extremely welcome,
especially in this present moment of 2022.
So, please join me in
welcoming Hilary Hahn.
(audience applauding)
- It's such an honor to be here.
Thank you for being here together,
all together to celebrate this.
And I'm looking forward
to the conversation
and taking some questions
from the audience.
First, I thought I would play
a little bit of solo Bach
to get us all ready together.
And then, we'll proceed.
(lively violin music)
New strings.
(audience laughing)
(lively violin music)
(audience applauding)
- So that was, as you heard.
We are so appreciative
of you and you're...
Sure, I'll take some
water, if you're pouring.
- Yeah, sure.
- No, that was a beautiful
performance of Bach Sarabande.
- Thank you.
- Just really appreciative
of you sharing your music
with us today.
So, maybe one more round of applause.
(audience applauding)
So maybe just to start,
let's pick a up on Bach.
I know it has clearly some
very special meaning to you.
It was your first album, that
"Hilary Hahn Plays Bach".
That's quite a statement.
But, I'm just curious
if you can tell us more
about your relationship
to the music of Bach.
- Yeah. I started my recording
career with solo Bach,
because I was 16 and it was the music
that I played the most.
And it just felt like if
I'm gonna record something,
I should record something that
I've played a lot. (laughs)
And I'm really glad I did,
because starting with a solo album,
I got to learn all about
the recording process
without the pressure of time.
We recorded all night,
multiple nights in a row.
Each piece had its own
separate time of the year.
We really had the luxury to take our time.
And I got to learn about recording,
I got to learn about
playbacks and about acoustics
and how it sounds different under the mics
from how it sounds when you're
playing for the audience.
So I really was working
with such an expert team.
And if I hadn't started with that,
I think I wouldn't have been
so inclined to be involved.
And these days I co-produce my records,
I am involved in every aspect.
Sometimes I run the sessions.
If it's a very small crew,
sometimes I let the
producer run the session.
But I have so much experience now,
and I'm really glad that
I started with that.
But I will say when I first proposed that,
as the repertoire for that first album,
it felt very natural to
me, but back then it was,
back in the '90s, this
is still 20th century.
(Mary laughing)
Back then it was kind
of taboo for a teenager
to be playing Bach or be, I
suppose, projecting authority
on the music of Bach
or Brahms or Beethoven.
It was sort of seen as further
along in your career material
and pretty audacious.
And I think there was a little pushback
inside the record company,
but I didn't know that.
So, I just went ahead and did it. (laughs)
But now, I think because
I was so convinced
of my playing of it, it
was so comfortable for me
and I enjoy the intricacies of it.
It just comes very naturally to me,
although it never feels
totally natural to play it.
But the ideas feel like they make sense
when I'm playing his music.
I think because of that, when
I was the teenager recording
and releasing Bach, it made it okay later.
So I definitely see people
starting their recording careers
with solo Bach now, and
I'm like... (laughs)
You're welcome. (laughs)
But, it was an honor to be
able to start with that.
- So when we were walking in,
we were playing your newer
album, the Virtuoso album.
So, lots have changed in between.
- Yeah, that album is,
it's called a compilation,
and usually the record
companies put it together.
- I see.
- But I actually put it together.
It's my favorite tracks from
a lot of my different albums,
and my favorites for different reasons.
Like, I might have an emotional
attachment to one project.
I might remember working on
this one with the composer.
Or like this, whenever
I play it as an encore,
it's a big hit and therefore I
really feel like the audience
connects with it, and
so when I listen to it
I remember all those great
performance experiences.
And so, that's what I was doing
with that record. (chuckles)
- So how different is that newer record
from the Retrospective
record, which you did in 2018.
Now, was that something the
record company put together
or you curated that too?
- I curated that as well,
but I added some tracks
that I had performed live.
And so, it's kind of nice.
It's nice to go back and look
at the work that you've done
and not have someone else pick
out their favorite things,
but really put together...
It's like playlists on a
really big scale. (laughs)
And it's kind of surprising
to me, because every time I do
a project, I'm just doing that project.
And when I count how
many records I've done,
I'm like, "How did that all happen?"
But it's just really
chipping away at things,
one little part of a project at a time
and having ideas that I follow through on.
- So, I noticed that between
the 2018 Retrospective
and the 2020 Virtuoso,
there's some repeats.
So, clearly these are some
of your favorites, right?
Can we talk about some of them?
- Sure.
- How did they become
some of your favorites?
Like the Paganini
Concerto, I think is one.
And the Higdon Concerto
must be another one.
- Mm-hmm.
How do I detangle the threads?
Actually, I don't know if...
I think of sort of the
overarching experience.
I think when I'm thinking
about my favorite tracks
from records, it's more
like I listen to them
but it's the context in which they occur.
So, there are pieces that
I learned with my teacher
and pieces that I taught myself.
And there's all sorts of
different transitions.
There are pieces that I commissioned,
there are projects that I started.
And I think with Paganini
it's such virtuoso music
but I find the beauty in the phrasing.
I kind of like looking at something
that is thought of one way and showing
that it's actually much
more complicated than that.
There are many other aspects that exist.
And the same with a commissioned work.
I don't like to look at it as just,
"Let's play the notes
and get it out there."
It's really, "How can we
already work to find,"
as performers, whoever the
combination of performers is
for this particular
performance, "How can we find
our interpretation to really
bring this music across
to the audience as a complete piece?"
If I think about what
Brahms would've sounded like
to a new audience, if the
performers had no idea
of phrasing traditions, and
then I make that leap in my head
to what we assume now of
Brahms with all the traditions,
we know the structure,
we've heard a lot of those works a lot.
That's my job in a new piece.
My job is to do that leap
and get it to the place
where there are clear phrases,
where the music can really
speak to the audience.
Not just play it through
and say it's a premier,
but really make it a whole
experience for the audience,
because when it starts that
way, it can then evolve
as other players pick it up.
I believe the energy you put
into any piece that you play,
but especially the first
performance of a piece
kind of sets it on its journey.
And if you give it a big,
good shove away from the dock,
then you're like, "Yes."
And it's all set to, if it's
a ship, it's all set to sail.
Then that is really, I think,
the best thing you could do
for a new piece of music.
- Can you describe that in terms of...
Or go in a little more
detail about that in relation
to the Jennifer Higdon piece?
- Mm-hmm.
So I met Jennifer, as
you mentioned, in the...
Let's see, how old was I?
I was 15.
So, it was the mid '90s,
and she had just graduated from Curtis.
And she hadn't yet become
inundated with commissions,
but it was coming.
She was getting busier and busier.
And I was her student,
and she was a really enlightening teacher.
She taught 20th century music history,
and brought it from the very
beginning of the 20th century
all the way into the present day.
Each week, we learned about
one or two new composers
that we hadn't studied before.
And the way she would teach,
she would put just like
some keywords on the board
and then we'd listen.
And it wasn't teaching the
facts about a composer.
It was teaching the ideas,
it was teaching us what to
listen to, how to listen,
how to pick things apart,
but not in an analytical way,
but more of like an emotional connection
to what we were hearing and
defining that for ourselves.
And there were some
facts on the board too,
but we were never quizzed on those.
We were quizzed on how
we related to the music.
And I think that was a
great way to get to know her
as a composer, because she is
very specific in her music.
She really wants the score
to be like she writes,
but she doesn't write anything
extra that she doesn't need
to have in there.
And the music has a lot of energy,
and it communicates immediately.
It's almost clearer for
the audience than it is
for the player.
So my challenge with that
concerto has always been
to embody it as much as the
audience hears me embodying it.
It's very clear music to listen
to, but in the middle of it,
there's all this stuff going on.
So you kind of have to keep your center
and keep aware of all the cues,
but also the momentum is
super important in her music.
- So how much did you
work with her directly
to kind of bring that music to life?
- I like to leave composers be.
I like to not have them second
guessing when they're writing
and just write what they wanna write,
and then give me what they
feel they've completed.
Not like the final draft, I
do like to see it (laughs)
before they finalize it.
But basically, I just try to get the music
and then we talk about
things that may or may not be
so practical or may or may
not communicate the way
that they might be
trying to communicate it.
- [Mary] I'm curious.
I mean, several people
have now played it at this
point, so what do you hear
when you hear others
playing that concerto?
- I haven't heard anyone else play it.
- [Mary] Oh, you haven't?
- They play it, but I
haven't been there. (laughs)
- [Mary] Oh yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, I would love to hear it.
But I think that the pieces...
It has a very strong personality,
so I think it's gonna
sound like the same piece
no matter who is playing it.
- I see.
- And having recorded it, I
always try to record the pieces
that are written for me,
so that there's a document.
So that push from the doc is global,
so that anyone who wants to hear it,
anyone who wants to learn
it, there's a precedent,
and they can just build on that.
I find it a lot easier as a player myself
to have something to listen
to before I play a piece.
So even if a piece is
newly written for me,
I will make my own practice
recording and listen to it
and get it in my head.
And that's how I develop
my interpretation.
I listen to what I did and I think,
"What would I wanna do
differently from that player?"
And then I kind of develop it from there.
- I can't help but wonder
if that's a little bit
at the early Suzuki to training. (laughs)
- Maybe. (laughs)
- Listening to the piece
before you play it.
- Yeah, maybe. It could be.
- Who knows?
But speaking of new music,
you've definitely been a
big supporter of new music
and contemporary composers.
So the album 27 Pieces for example,
is a great example of that.
So, I just wanna hear your philosophy
towards contemporary music.
What are you looking for
when you're asking people
to commission a work for you?
- For that album, I think I didn't realize
what I was taking on.
I got really excited and I
commissioned a lot of people
with a lot of different styles.
And I was thinking in terms of minutes.
I was like, "Okay, I've done concerti."
I hadn't commissioned anything shorter
than a concerto before.
So I was thinking, if I commission...
If they're all three to five minute pieces
and I commission 10, so then
10 will feel like a concerto.
And then it'll just be
preparing two or three concerti
and I can do that over time.
And I didn't realize each
piece is about as much
of a learning curve as an entire concerto.
So, it was learning.
I'd only worked with two
of the composers before,
so it was learning the
style and the intentions
and the musical language
of 27 composers, or 26.
And I did an open contest
for the final encore,
which was always something I wanted.
I wanted to open it up, have
accessibility for people
whose music had not yet been recorded,
that I may not have come across.
And I picked a winner
out of nearly 400 entries
that came in.
So when we received almost 400 entries,
I called a friend and I was like,
"Can you just help sort through them?"
Because they were supposed
to be blind entries
and I didn't want anyone
to get disqualified
because they'd forgotten
to take the title out
or forgotten to remove their name.
So I had some people
help me out just sort of
sorting through the contest,
and so I had volunteers.
It was really nice.
It was a big project.
But doing that, it was important
to me to find composers
whose music I felt compelled to play.
I was curious when I heard their music,
I was curious what they would write
for a violin and piano duo,
and I just couldn't let it go.
So, that's my sign whenever
I'm working on an idea.
If I cannot let the idea go,
if I can't stop talking about it,
even once I've convinced people.
They're like, "Yeah, we
get it. We're on board."
I'm like (mumbling).
That's my sign that it's
something I have to do.
I'm just not gonna be able to sleep on it
and it'll fade away.
And so that was how I approached
which composers I commissioned.
- And then people yes right away?
'Cause I imagine, if
Hilary Hahn is writing you,
yes is the answer. (laughs)
- Well, one of them...
I did a lot of cold calls,
'cause I didn't know them.
So I would get their number
from their agent or just,
I don't know, a mutual
friend or something, someone.
And I would give them a call.
Maybe their website. (laughs)
And one of them thought it
was a student prank calling,
so didn't call back.
(Marie and audience laughing)
So I called again and he was
like, "Oh, sorry." (laughs)
- It really is you. (laughs)
- But it was a lot of cold calls,
a lot of, "Hi, I'm Hilary
Hahn. I'm doing a project.
(Mary and audience laughing)
Do you think you'd be interested?"
And also I wasn't sure about the politics,
like asking these great
contemporary composers
to write short pieces for starters.
There's a bit of an issue
sometimes with composers
being asked to write the
first piece of a program,
sort of the overture or being
asked to write short pieces.
But it was really a
statement about the span
of contemporary styles
and expression through all
of this range of styles.
That's what I was going for.
And so I was hoping that the
composers would understand
the scope of the project.
But then I wasn't sure if they
would like being on a project
with so many other composers.
Turns out they were all really open-minded
and supportive of each other,
and it was really nice.
Sometimes I got to introduce
two composers to each other
and just sit there at post concert dinner.
They would both have come to the concert,
because they both coincidentally
be in the same city.
And very different people,
totally different styles of music,
getting to know each
other, just made so happy
to introduce these creative people
and get to kind of observe the experience.
- So, you didn't really
have people coming together
during the writing process?
- Mm-mm. And some of
them I never have met.
I communicated with them by
phone, or in German. (laughs)
One of them doesn't do
email, doesn't speak English,
doesn't have a phone.
(Mary laughing)
And so, his daughter speaks German
and lives in another country
and can communicate with him.
And so he sent the music,
and then I just kind of had
a couple questions about the score.
So I got the answers, it's
like a game of telephone.
And I was like, "Okay, I think the piece
is just gonna play itself then." (laughs)
And that's the thing,
when you're a performer and
you're working with new music,
you are given the responsibility
of interpreting it,
bringing it to life.
But there's also within
that responsibility,
a sense of judgment.
You have to use your judgment
to figure out how closely
you adhere to the score,
how much you take on board
what the composer says.
And ultimately, it has to
feel like the music is in you
and it's natural to you.
So, I always try to get
the composer's feedback.
Maybe I send them a practice recording.
If we're in the same place,
I'll do a coaching session
with them in person, and
then I'll try one more time.
If I can, I'll send them
one more practice recording
to see if I interpreted what they told me
and have incorporated it in a way
that they're comfortable with.
But it's definitely a process,
and you have to give over
some of your creative
license for a little while.
And then ultimately, you have
to understand the personality
of the composer.
One composer will write Roberto,
and mean it starts slowly and goes faster.
And another will mean the opposite.
And there's nothing to say what they mean.
To them, it's obvious.
So you have to look at it,
examine every detail and say,
"Now, when you say Roberto,
what does that mean to you?"
And sometimes it's an emotional thing.
Sometimes it's very specific.
Sometimes it's just,
"Oh, you just play it
however you wanna play it."
It's really interesting.
And I also did a published
edition for the 27 Encores.
One of the things I love
about working with composers
is looking at the score and
just seeing how do they express
their music in writing?
And it was such a project,
because they were doing...
They were using all
different software programs.
Some sent in handwritten scores.
Some had no bar lines.
So, where do you put a rehearsal number?
(Mary laughing)
But, it was conceptual.
It was always intentional.
And it always said something
about their creative process.
So in the addition, at first,
the first draft of the addition,
the publisher did house standards
for all of the markings.
Like, "This is where we put the slur.
This is where we put dynamics."
Not necessarily replicating
what was in the version
the composer turned in.
And I looked at it and I said,
"This doesn't even look
like the same piece.
We have to go back to the
drawing board and start over.
We have to reset all of these,
because they have to look
different when you flip through."
If a composer was minimal,
it has to look minimal.
If it was a composer
writing five instructions
for every note, which I kid you
not is in one of the pieces,
everyone has to be
lined up very precisely.
We can't have any floating
markings anywhere.
If you're gonna do a column of five,
it has to be a column of five.
Not two on top, three on
the bottom, fit it wherever.
Because when you're playing,
you have to look at it
a certain way, and it's
an experience of reading
and translating that into playing.
Anyone who works with me
knows I put a lot of attention
into the details, because it's important.
It's really important when
working with composers,
because you're starting a document.
The performance is a document.
How many times do we have
discussions in rehearsal about,
"What about the composer?
Did they mean Mezzo-Forte
here, or a piano there?"
If you are premiering something
and you do an addition,
you're responsible in
a way for making sure
if you know something about the piece
and you see that it's not
showing up in the score,
you have to put it in there
for the sake of the composer,
because no one can get everything right.
- Speaking of documentation,
I'm just curious how much
social media, like YouTube,
has really changed that.
So, do you feel like people
know you and your music
through recordings or more
through YouTube these days?
I'm just curious.
- That's a good question.
I think that people's consumption
patterns have changed.
I used to be mad at YouTube.
I'm not mad at YouTube anymore.
- [Mary] Why were you out at YouTube?
- Because, almost everything
on there was pirated
and people were very proud
of spending a lot of time
watching and listening to me on YouTube.
And they thought they were supporting me,
but they actually weren't in a
business sense supporting me.
And I would be trying to
sell records post concert,
and people would be like,
"I watch all of your YouTube videos."
And I'm like, "Thank you." (laughs)
But don't get me wrong,
I just really appreciate the enthusiasm.
And I eventually realized
that that's not really
what YouTube is about.
YouTube isn't about business.
YouTube, for me.
The industry I'm in, the
performances are the business.
And the recordings,
yes, it is an industry,
it is a business, but
as far as the purpose,
the purpose for me is
having the music out there
as much as possible.
So when I record something,
I'm recording it for a purpose.
I'm not recording it because
I wanna record my version.
I'm recording it because
I think there's value
in something I'm doing
in it existing out there
for the sake of the piece.
And that's why I record all the new stuff.
So then if it's on YouTube,
if my performances are on YouTube,
if it makes a difference in someone's life
to watch the YouTube video, it's great.
'Cause I can't be
everywhere at the same time.
And I do notice that
students have grown up
watching my videos, so it's a
different feeling for me now.
I remember watching
videos that were pirated
when I was a student.
But they were videos of Heifetz,
Elman, Milstein, Kaiser.
Anything I could find
that was an older video,
and they were really formative.
So I just kind of look
at it differently now,
and I appreciate the connective
aspect of social media,
including YouTube, it's also evolved.
YouTube is different, it's
a different experience.
It has a different
presence in people's lives
than when it started.
- [Mary] Yeah, along the lines
of recording and promoting
different composers, I know
you've done a lot in terms of
wanting to promote female
composers, composers of color,
so I wanna just hear more
your philosophy about that
in terms of trying to open up
the world of classical music.
- I think it was actually
the 27 Encores project
that I'm thinking about when my philosophy
on streaming changed, because
I noticed that with...
When I was listening,
when I was really trying
to find composers for the project,
I really appreciated
the streaming services
that would suggest the next thing.
And that wasn't necessarily the
case back when I was putting
the project together.
It was about, over 10 years ago.
So what we take for granted in
our listening experience now
is something that has
developed in my career,
in the course of my career.
And I was able to access composers' music
that wouldn't have been on
the shelf in the record store
through Google searches
and through searching
through various video
channels and also YouTube
and all of that.
At that point, that's when I
let go of my misunderstanding
about the purpose of streaming.
And I'm one of the artists
who actually is like,
"You know what? Music
is very multifaceted."
It's about reaching the audience,
and it's about people
respecting the music.
So, if that's what's happening
through the experience,
people are getting the
emotional connection they need
and hearing the voices they need to hear,
then that's what it's about.
And in that same way,
I've obviously been noticing
gaps in my repertoire.
I grew up in a time when at Conservatory,
we really didn't learn new music at all.
And my teacher was born in 1907,
so his contemporaries were
Barber, Bernstein, Prokofiev.
And so I got the feeling
of knowing, as a performer,
knowing a composer.
But it was just not quite
up to date at that time.
And now it's a different
experience for students.
But I would say that I
definitely prioritized...
I really tried with the 27
Encores to balance that project.
I looked for composers from
different parts of the globe.
But I realized in reexamining everything
over the past few years that I thought
that I had good representation
in it, and I didn't.
I had definitely fallen into bias gaps,
and I definitely had not
taken some things on board
that I should have taken on board.
And so now, after all
of the racial reckoning,
after George Floyd's murder,
I wound up just taking
a step back because I wasn't
performing at the time anyway.
So I took a step back and
I reexamined every layer
of my work.
And I was like, "Where
am I losing the thread?
Which voices are not present?
How did that happen?
What's going on there? (chuckles)
How did I arrive at this point?"
And how could I go back
and be more inclusive,
have better representation.
And I'm obviously still
learning, it's a lifelong thing.
But I reexamined all of
the projects I had going.
I re-shifted them.
And so I think from now,
people will start to see
that I am putting emphasis on
representing as many voices
as possible, because I
think contemporary music
and contemporary musical
projects are a place
where we can allow people to express
their lived experiences.
We look back in history,
we put things together
about Mozart's life with
current events at that time.
But everything being written
now, and things being written
by people whose voices haven't been heard,
those are part of a historical document
about the human experience.
So we need to have people's experiences
put into music and played.
Not every experience can
be expressed in words.
There are a lot of feelings put into music
that can never be in
a historical document.
A lot of people will
watch historical films
to get the feel for what it
might have been like to live
in that time, or what did
people speak like back then?
Or, we have performance
practice and we listen.
So we need to keep that musical
record going for the future,
for 100 years from now,
150 years, 200 years,
so that people playing
that music can be like,
"That's what it felt like to
be this person at this time."
And no one is a monolith,
so we need to take people
as their full human selves
and allow them to say
what they need to say
and get out of the way.
Sharing the spotlight is not
about being in the spotlight
with someone else all the time.
Sometimes it's just giving
someone the spotlight
and getting out of it,
and so that's something
that I've been trying to
do more of these days.
- So, when are we gonna see
a new project from you then?
(Hilary laughing)
- Well, I've already started
premiering some solo encores
by composers of color.
The reason I've been
commissioning solo encores
is because I have complete
programming freedom with them.
The short pieces I can play
in every single concert.
So I can play them with an
orchestra, without the orchestra.
When I would normally play solo Bach,
I can play a piece by a
contemporary composer.
If I'm on the radio or
I have a TV appearance,
if a piece is three to four
minutes long, too long for TV,
but I can program it in a lot
of short form performances.
It's just me and the violin,
so I can do whatever.
So, that's why I'm focusing
on that solo encore form,
which is something that I
missed with the duo encores.
People would want to hear
them, but there's no piano
on stage after I play
with orchestra. (laughs)
I do a solo Bach recital,
there's no piano there.
So, what do I play is as an
encore? More solo Bach. (laughs)
But, it's a really
interesting thing to look
at the programming.
I don't control most of
the programs that I'm on,
I'm a guest.
So, what can I do?
And I think that's also
a theme of my career.
"What do I really have in front of me,
and what can I do with it?
And how can I do more than what
I initially think I can do?"
So, for example, with
the Project 440 donation,
I tied that to a larger
fundraising campaign.
So out of 25,000, we raised 50,000.
So, looking at it like being
creative and making the most
out of what you have.
And then with that, they were able to hire
a new full-time person.
So it's kind of, also with repertoire,
I look at it that way.
When I have an opportunity,
what can I do with that opportunity,
and how can I be helpful
with that opportunity?
- [Mary] That's great.
You're so busy.
- So, I did premier actually did...
So, there are two pieces.
So there's one piece by Michael Abels
that I premiered during the pandemic.
And there's a piece that I
just premiered the other day
by Barbara (indistinct),
and she's now a big composer
who lives up north in Turtle
Island, which is North America.
And she wrote a lot of the
indications in the music
in Ojibwe, but she also trained
in a Hochschule in Munich.
So, she's got a very avant
garde European composition
tradition as well as
growing up in the bush
and being a nature guide,
playing native flute
and getting a lot of her
ideas during ceremonies.
So it's really interesting, I think.
We need to listen to the
voices that are creating
and really put things
together in ways and programs
that help us see a bigger picture.
- So as you're doing this, I
know that you also rerecorded,
or maybe, I say rerecorded
as though you did it before,
but you recorded books one
through three of Suzuki.
Is that correct?
- They've had several
iterations of recordings.
And so, I didn't rerecord my recording,
but I recorded a new
version at there invitation.
- So, what inspired you
to pick that project up?
- They asked me.
And, it was nice.
I mean, I was the first woman
to do an official recording
for the Suzuki violin repertoire.
A lot of the Suzuki teachers are women,
so I felt good about that.
But mostly just the emotional
connection to Suzuki,
because I started with it.
And I remember all those pieces.
When I was in the sessions,
there's a representative
from Suzuki who's there as an expert,
because I can't just play
the pieces however I want.
I need to keep in mind how
the students need to hear them
for training purposes and for speed.
I can't just take off in a tempo and then-
- [Mary] Just zip through book one.
- Yeah. (laughs)
I can't just be totally
free with all the rhythm
and do full vibrato.
I mean, I could, but then
it wouldn't be helpful.
It would kind of be counterproductive.
So, there was someone
there as a sounding board
for those questions.
And sometimes I would have
an instinct about the rhythm
and I'd say, "Should I wait?"
And they're like, "Yes,
yes. That's the tradition.
You just hold that and then start the beat
on the next note."
And that was just so deeply embedded in me
from having learned that
music a really long time ago.
So, it was really very nice.
And as I was recording,
I was thinking about how
these are the recordings that
all the little Suzuki kids
and their families are
gonna be listening to.
- In car rides and carpools.
- Yeah.
- Nonstop. (laughs)
It was really a big honor,
because that's a big responsibility,
but also really sweet.
- Yeah. So, I just wanna transition maybe
to some of your less traditional projects.
So in terms of, I think social media,
you have #100daysofpractice.
I promised the audience
we'd ask about that.
(Hilary laughing)
And you just told me-
- I just finished.
- You just finished 100 days of practice.
So, tell us a little bit about that.
And maybe this will,
we'll start to wrap it up
and open it up to the audience.
- Okay.
So, it began for me as a
response to a visual arts project
that I saw posted on Instagram.
And the suggestion from
the host of that project
was just to pick a topic.
So it's like 100 days of whatever
but it's work in progress,
not to post your finished work.
'Cause there was, at that time
with visual art on Instagram,
there was an issue kind of
like of people only posting
their best stuff, and it
being kind of intimidating
to be there in that scene.
And it was a way of opening
up the behind the scenes
to be more public.
And I like to draw for fun.
And I was like, "Maybe I'll
just draw for 100 days."
I was like, "No one wants to see that,
and I don't think I'll
be drawing for 100 days.
(indistinct) 100 days of drawing."
So, I thought I should do a
hundred days of something...
'Cause, I mean, I
desperately wanted to belong
to this visual arts project.
(Mary and audience laughing)
I was like the unpopular kid
who's trying to be in the crowd
and they're like, "I'll
just do this little thing
on the side, and maybe you'll notice me."
- [Mary] So something
tells me if you actually
posted 100 pictures,
people would look at that.
- You would be surprised.
- [Mary] "People, look
at what I'm drawing."
- You would be surprised.
It's interesting.
People are very into
me playing the violin.
(Mary and audience laughing)
So people are very kind and
tolerate my other ideas,
but me playing the violin
is really what people
are there for.
And so I just wanted to kind
of participate in this project,
but in a way that was natural to me.
And so I was like, "Practice anyway.
I should practice anyway.
So, I'll just do that."
And I didn't honestly think that anyone
would care, or notice.
I thought if anything,
it would be annoying,
because it wasn't finished material.
And we're not taught that
practice is something anyone
wants to hear.
If anything, we're taught that
no one wants to hear practice
and that we shouldn't be playing
through like a performance
when we're practicing.
It should be practice, but
it's not a performance.
It's not for public consumption.
And so I was just thinking,
"Oh, I better be ready
with some good content after
all this is over. (laughs)
And for the people who stuck around."
And I started getting feedback
during the first 100 days
that it was really making
people feel comfortable
about their own practice.
And people thought it was very brave of me
to post my practice.
But I go on stage in front
of thousands of people
and perform those.
There's nothing brave about
playing not particularly well
for the camera and putting it up there.
It didn't, for me, translate
into an act of courage.
It was just something very
inconsequential, I thought.
But seeing that really made me
realize exactly how isolating
practice usually is, and how
much pressure we're taught
to put on ourselves in practice.
I mean, I equate practicing
as a student to being told
to stand in front of the mirror,
pick out everything you
don't like about yourself
and fix it all by yourself,
and then present yourself
to a judge to see if you got better.
That's really what it is.
I mean, you are really
going into the practice room
to find problems with your playing,
to figure out how to solve them.
The problems are there,
'cause you don't know
how to fix them.
How are you supposed to fix
something that you're doing,
because you don't know how to fix it?
And then there's a deadline
of a lesson or something
and you just...
It's a really uncomfortable experience.
And I have arrived at
a place where, for me,
practice is about experimenting,
finding solutions.
You can't force something
that's not ready to happen.
So just meandering around
it, trying this, trying that.
And all the while I do have
very high pressure deadlines,
however whatever I do
in the practice room,
that's as far as I will get
with that piece at that time.
Then I go out and I play it
and I learn something on stage
and I'm like, "Okay,
there's something else
I need to figure out.
Let me just do what I can."
Perform it.
"That didn't work. Let's see.
Let's try this little other idea."
And that's been such a
healthier process for me.
I think about the pressure
of practicing every day
from when we're little.
We were talking about this earlier.
There's nothing I do every day of my life
besides survival things.
I don't wanna watch my favorite
movie 100 days in a row.
I don't do anything the same
for 365 days of the year,
except I do, fortunately,
have a place to live.
I have a bed to sleep
in, I have food to eat.
Those are the things I do every day.
And not everyone has access to that,
so I recognize that privilege.
But practicing is not a survival skill.
I think we need to keep that in mind.
It's a lifelong experiment,
and it's a lifelong pursuit.
And it's for you to find out
who you are as a musician
without anyone watching you.
The pressure is off
when you're practicing.
That's what practice should be.
And so the more I realize that
by reading people's comments,
doing these 100 days of practice seasons,
the more I realize how important
it is to talk about that.
Take the pressure off.
It's your time to do your thing your way.
- So that realization only
is recent for you then,
because the 100 days started
about five, six years ago.
- Mm-hmm.
Yeah. I think also
watching myself practice
and seeing how I work, 'cause I didn't see
how I worked before.
And also just growing into
who I am as a musician.
I've always been trying to find my flow
even when I was already
performing full time.
Yeah, always trying to
align what I wanted to do
with what I was actually doing.
What do I wanna communicate,
versus what people
are hearing from me.
So, that was what I did in practice.
That was what practice was for.
- So, probably the last
question and then we'll open up
to the floor is that, this sounds...
You just described yourself
in such a serious way.
And it just seems like
maybe some of the videos
and some of the projects you've done
are not quite as serious.
So, for example, you appearing
on stage with TwoSet Violin
hula hooping to and playing Paganini.
- But I double-octaved it.
(Mary laughing)
- How many of you have seen that?
(Hilary laughing)
So that definitely tells me you
have a great sense of humor.
And we've been laughing
throughout all of today.
- I take my work really seriously.
It's a big responsibility.
And there are a lot of
people who save up money
to buy tickets for concerts.
They save up money to buy records.
A lot of people give their
time to listen to my work,
and I take it really
seriously just to do my best
to create an emotional connection
and emotional experience
and not to have anything
get in the way of that.
And that's why I work really hard.
But I love music.
I love performing.
I love that feeling of
connecting with everyone.
I look at music as a public service,
even though it's a business.
It's called an industry,
but it's something
that we can provide for each other.
I get things from the audience
that I don't get from myself
in normal life.
And I hope I give things to
the audience in performance.
I give feelings and
experiences and moments
with my colleagues.
I hope that those are
meaningful to people.
And when you get comments
from people like...
Well, you see someone
when they're a student,
like years ago, I would meet
someone who's kind of my age,
like a teenager, I meet
them after a concert.
And then 10 years later
they're coming to the concert,
and then they bring their baby.
And then the kid plays an instrument.
10 years later, they're at the...
And it's nice.
You realize that you're
part of people's lives
and they really...
There's a role that play in someone's life
and you don't exactly know
what's meaningful to whom
at which times, so I take every
performance really seriously
because in every concert
there's someone experiencing
my current feeling.
So if I'm honest with my playing,
and I really express my
feeling, that person who needs
that format to understand
that feeling in themselves
or acknowledge that feeling themselves,
that won't be really meaningful for them.
There was a concert
recently where, I think,
my colleague and I were super
exhausted and we're like,
"We're gonna get it
together for the concert.
We're gonna do it."
And then I was like, "I
bet you there's someone
in the audience tonight who
is celebrating a birthday."
And then sure enough after
the concert, someone was like,
"My parents got me this ticket
a year ago for my birthday,
and I've been looking forward
to it, and here we are."
I've had people tell me that
this particular recording
was playing in their
parents' room during hospice,
or their baby was born to this music.
And I'm like, "I'm just one person."
But there's this whole continuum of music,
and it's really meaningful.
And to be given the
opportunity to communicate
through this music,
it's a really big deal
that I don't take lightly.
So even in the TwoSet
thing, I was practicing it.
I am maybe not the best hula hooper,
but I can keep it going.
I practiced the hula hooping.
I didn't just go out there and do it.
I practiced at home with Paganini.
I practiced my Paganini.
I don't just walk in and toss things off,
but I also love spontaneity
and I love the moment.
So, I just always try to be
prepared for those moments
so that when something important happens,
I can just step into it and
absorb all that feeling.
- Well, I have to say it
was really, really fun
to be in the audience.
And all of a sudden there
you were with the hula hoop.
- No one knew I was watching
the show beforehand either.
- No, we did not know. (laughs)
And everyone around
was losing their minds.
(Hilary laughing)
"Oh my God that's Hilary
Hahn with a hula hoop.
What is she gonna do with a hula hoop?"
- It's funny when your name
becomes like an expression.
Like, "Hilary Hahn."
I don't go through life, like
I'm walking down the hall,
I'm like, "I'm Hilary Hahn."
(Mary and audience laughing)
But everyone is like,
"That's Hilary Hahn."
- That just happened down here.
- "I'm Hilary, hello."
Or, "Ms. Hahn."
For me, my name is like
two separate words.
It's like, TwoSet Violin, Hilary Hahn.
"Is that Hilary Hahn?"
"That's Hilary Hahn."
It's funny.
It's really cute, I really
appreciate the acknowledgement.
- I think on that fun
note, let's let's pause
and let's hear from the audience.
So I do have two of our wonderful
aides, or is it just one?
Okay.
So while they get situated...
So it's COVID, so we're
not passing the mic.
I mean, if you can go to the
other side, that'd be great.
And then I think the idea then
is, if you have a question,
raise your hand and either
Andrew or May will come.
And just speak the question
that one of them will speak
into the microphone.
So, don't pass the mic.
Yeah, so just tell him
the question and then...
And May, you'll speak into the microphone.
- [May] Oh, I see.
- Got it.
- We have a human amplifier.
- We're trying to be COVID safe.
So, you're just holding the microphone.
- No, no, wait.
I got it, I got it.
Everyone, sit down.
(Mary laughing)
You can sit down.
Thank you.
And then you say your question
to your human amplifier,
who then has a microphone.
- And he will repeat.
- Yes.
Thank you.
- [Andrew] While we're over
here, Alvin here has a question.
- Great.
- Okay, your next. (laughs)
- [Andrew] So Alvin asks,
if you've ever had any times
that you've felt unnerving to play.
Maybe even a little
bit nervous even though
you've practiced a lot, even
despite performing so often
over your career.
Or unmotivated, is a
caveat to the question,
unmotivated to practice.
- Unmotivated.
Would you like me to
talk about the practice
or the performance experience?
- [Andrew] It was more so
being unmotivated to play
and just not feeling like
you were playing with feeling
and emotions even though
you've been playing
for such a long time.
So the jist is (indistinct).
- Okay. I did hear that one.
- Okay, great.
- So, how do I continue
to play with feeling
even though I'm unmotivated?
This is something I've
been working on constantly
all of my life as a musician.
And I think I finally landed on something.
So, maybe I can give you a
little tip to leapfrog you over
20 years of figuring it out.
I play what I'm feeling in the moment.
I used to think that I should
plan it, I should practice it.
This is how I want to play.
My interpretation of something
was a series of decisions
and a style, but the problem
was I kept getting reviews,
comments on the YouTube videos
like, "She sounds robotic.
It's not expressive."
And I'm like, "I'm
pouring myself into this.
What's not connecting?"
I would get reviews constantly
about great technique,
but kind of reserved musicality.
And I just was like a puddle
at the end of the concert.
I was so worn out and I was forcing
all of the possible emotion in.
It was only when I started
doing solo Bach recitals,
for the first time, like a few years ago.
I never played a solo recital before,
because I loved working with people,
and I didn't feel the need
to do a full solo recital.
But when I started doing it as a project,
I realized that I was
second-guessing myself too much
to get through a concert.
I just was not feeling like I was...
I was in a very uncomfortable
psychological state
when it was just me and I
was trying to do a thing.
I was trying to do this,
I was trying to do that.
Always judging what I
was doing as I was going.
And I just, on the third concert I decided
I'm just gonna stay...
I was working on this in the
masterclass a little bit today.
So, this is a little bit of background
on how I arrived there.
So I just decided I'm just
gonna stay on these notes
until I feel like I'm done
with them, the whole concert.
Every note I'm gonna be in it
as long as I need to be in it.
Whether that's shorter than I
planned, longer than I planned
slower, faster, in good
taste, not in good taste.
I am just going to enjoy every
note and not think ahead,
not think back for an hour and a half.
And it was so cleansing.
And so, also healing as a musician.
You're trying, trying, trying,
trying, trying, trying.
You're analyzing yourself,
trying to get better,
trying to do this, trying to
do that, trying to do that.
"Did I do it? Did I not do it?
How good was that concert?"
Just to be in every note as it went by.
And it took me all of
those decades of experience
to be able to do that
and recognize when I was
in the right note at the
right time, for myself.
But, the reviews were entirely different.
The feedback on my
social media commentary,
totally different.
And I was like, "That's what
I needed to do all along."
I needed to be in my space
emotionally, whatever that was.
And so now, instead of working
against whatever's happening
in my day, that idea,
"The show must go on."
The show must go on,
because we feel things,
not despite things going wrong.
You have a flu and you go...
Don't take this.
Don't go work with COVID, whatever.
But when I was growing up,
it's like, "Are you sick?
Can you perform?"
If you can, you go out and
do it despite being sick.
Now, it would be like, "Am I low energy?"
The show must go on
because I'm low energy,
and I'm gonna change my energy
in the course of the show.
So, I'll start performing low energy.
I'll be like, "Just not a
day where I'm gonna play
loud right now.
I don't have fast in me.
I don't have dynamic in me.
I'm going to really
take this energy down."
Even if it's the beginning
of the Brahms Concerto,
slow it down, take your time.
And then at some point,
you've identified with
that low energy and you're like,
"I'm sick of it. Let's go."
And then, then it picks up
and you've completely gone
through your own evolution
with the audience.
And you arrived honestly
at a different mood,
and everyone has been there with you.
And that I think is what is motivating.
Music is this channel
for you rather than this,
"Despite this, I have to do that."
If you can work with it, it's amazing.
And it's that thing, like
whatever you're going through,
there's someone out there
who hears it and feels it
and needs that.
So the more you can just
be true to yourself.
Obviously not...
You're working with colleagues,
you want to find a way
to connect with colleagues
and do that same
emotional honesty while playing.
I think that it is really a
very, very special conversation
at that point.
You could do that in practice too.
Just take a moment and,
"Where am I emotionally?
Why do I feel this resistance?
What is going on?"
And don't fix it, just be with that.
Just notice, it's that
idea, notice what's going on
and just say, "Okay."
Name it, notice it,
name it, leave it alone.
Just do your thing.
And I think it, then it's
not a matter of motivation,
it's a matter of living through it.
I think we had this question.
You've been so patient.
Now you can stand up.
Now you understand what's happening.
If you want to stand up,
you can stand up. (laughs)
- [Ray] Hi, Hilary.
- Hey.
- [Ray] Can you hear me okay?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, you have a big voice.
- [Ryan] I'm Ryan.
I'm a first year undergrad at
Yale, and I play the violin,
so this topic is especially
meaningful for me.
- Great.
- [Ray] Thank you so much
for being here with us.
- Thank you.
- [Ryan] I was just
wondering for those students
who might not necessarily be
pursuing a professional career
playing music, how can we still keep music
a daily part of our lives?
- This may be my own inclination,
but I think we can all make
the world better by connecting
and connecting with people we know,
connecting with people we don't know.
Music can be a conduit
for a lot of things.
So, I find that when I need to
keep things moving musically,
despite a lot...
'Cause a lot of my work has nothing to do
with playing the violin.
So, I'm always trying to
find time to practice.
And that's actually why 100
days of practice is good,
'cause then the work is
practicing. Yes! (laughs)
But when you don't have a lot of time,
maybe have an overarching goal.
What are you gonna do with the music?
What is the music gonna mean for you?
What's it gonna mean to the
other people in your life?
What's it gonna mean to the community?
You can maybe put together
just a little goal
of some community project.
And then the more you
collaborate with people,
the more you'll be forced
to prioritize the music.
And also you'll get
that feedback loop from,
when you're in school, you
have performance opportunities.
When you're not, you may not
So create ones that make a
difference for some other people,
and then it's not so much about delivering
the perfect performance from the stage.
It's about the purpose of music.
Everyone has individual ideas,
so your idea will be valid
and you'll be able to feel like
there's a real point to it,
which is very motivating
when you don't have
a lot of time as well.
That would be my suggestion. (chuckles)
- [Student] Hi.
- Hi.
- [Student] I'm also a first
year at Yale on my undergrad.
I'm not a violinist, but I've played piano
for the last 13 years.
But for me, in my
experience, (indistinct) work
goes into character content.
Even no matter how stressed
you are (indistinct) itself,
it's still a lot fun.
So my question is gonna be,
what is your favorite live
performance experience?
Performance experience you've had.
- Ever?
(Mary and audience laughing)
- [Student] Ever, or
in the last six months.
Whatever (indistinct) timeframe.
(Mary and audience laughing)
- I'm gonna take a two-pronged answer,
because there's actually a kind
of performance that evolved
during lockdowns that wound
up being a lot more meaningful
to me than I had expected,
but it was not a live
performance situation.
So, I prerecorded a
video of a world premier.
And then it was a global world premier.
It was Michael Abels'
piece, Isolation Variation.
And it was commissioned as
part of a virtual residency
at my request.
And I got to watch during the premier,
I got to watch who was
tuning in from where
around the world.
And usually world premieres
are just in a place
whoever can get there.
So, it's really just like a hall premier
that's the very first one in the world,
so it's a world premier.
But it's not a global world
premier all at the same time.
And so that, and then also
having that video then
that I can send to other
virtual performances
as a performance, it increases the reach
of contemporary music.
It increases the effectiveness
of one performance
that I recorded.
And so that's actually
been very special to me.
That's the most special performance
out of the lockdown experience.
And I think we need to
keep those things going,
because there's value in
that that we cannot achieve
in a live performance in a hall.
Obviously live performances
are not replicable virtually,
and so we need to keep looking
at ways that are individual
to live performances that
strengthen the strengths
of live performance, and then
other formats that strengthen
the strengths of virtual connections.
For a live performance experience,
I think personally the
most enlightening one was
that Bach recital where
everything clicked,
which happened to be at Lincoln Center.
So I was returning to Lincoln
Center which I played in as
which I played at as a teenager
and have played at since.
I've gone to performances
there, but I had the entire...
Oh, I don't know what
they call it anymore.
It used to be Alice Tully
Hall, and they renamed it.
And I was like an old person.
So, I'm stuck back in Alice Tully times.
But I was playing, and I was
the only person backstage.
I was the only person on stage.
I was the only person performing.
And when I left the hall and
they turned out the lights
for the hall, I was
like, "That was just me."
And that was the concert
where I stayed in every note.
And it was like this eternity
of a super special moment
that just, it just drew
me through through it.
And then the realization like,
"Wow, look where I've landed." (laughs)
I think no matter what we achieve in life,
it's important to look at where we are.
Where do we think we'd
be, and where are we now?
And what are we proud of right now?
In every class, in every
conversation with a student,
I always ask, "What are you proud of?"
Because I think we forget
to ask ourselves that.
So, I think the moments
where I've been able
to really sort of sit back and be like,
"Whoa, this is a very cool
thing that music enables."
Those are probably my
favorite performances.
- [Student] Thank you.
And I just wanted to mention,
since you did bring up what
our audience means to you
(indistinct)
(audience laughing)
(Hilary laughing)
- Have a good day. (laughs)
Oh, that's so cool.
I'll let you select the...
- Maybe the person in the Jean jacket.
That's you, yeah.
That is you, with red
shirt and Jean jacket, yes.
- Do you need a mic, or person?
You can say it and they
can translate it. (laughs)
- [Andrew] I'm just gonna give it to her.
- Okay.
Living dangerously. Okay.
- [Student] Thank you so
much for coming to Yale
and giving your talk.
It was really wonderful to hear you play.
I'm a master student
at the School of Music.
One of the things that
I'm very passionate about
is the intersection of media and music.
And one of your recent
projects was with David Lang,
and involved AI.
And I was curious about how
that came about and how you see
the future of music interacting
with the new forms of media
that is currently merging
and always changing
and transforming our art form.
- That was part of a
project that I co-founded.
So, that was something
that I was working on a lot
during part of my sabbatical
and also part of the season
that mostly was canceled, last season.
There's an AI scientist
named Carol Reiley who...
She and I go way back socially.
And we had been talking on the
phone about just a brainstorm
of like, "Where does
music and AI overlap?"
And I love talking with
people from different fields
and kind of interpreting
their knowledge into a musical
or artistic spectrum.
Kind of like when I go
to a museum and I see
the brush strokes of the
painting, or I see how an artist
sort of dug into the paper with a pen
and I can almost feel it
in my hand and translate it
to a bow stroke, what would
it feel like to make that art?
How can I make the sound
like that visual impression?
And so I do that same parallel
drawing with other art forms,
and I think AI...
Interestingly, I think this,
but AI scientists do not,
but I think AI is an art form,
because there's a lot of
interpretation in coding.
There's a lot of beauty in how AI programs
and systems are structured.
And AI is at a point right now with music,
where a lot of the foundation
code is being written
and a lot of the ethics
are being established.
And so, it just seemed an
interesting thing to explore.
Let's see where the state
of the art, arts (laughs)
where the state of the art is.
And let's see if these
composition programs work
for composers on a really
high interpretive level,
or is it more of a practical thing?
And so it was sort of
testing the systems a bit,
and it was tricky to find
composers who were interested
in that, because in a way
when you're composing,
it's hard enough without
having to learn a new language
of composition, having to be restricted.
But David has done a lot.
A couple other composers
were interested as well.
Michael Abels actually did
a piece that was premiered
by Dominic Cheli, wonderful
pianist based in LA.
And I was happy to see that
they kept working together.
It makes me so happy when people,
it's like artistic matchmaking.
And I'm like, "Aw, you go do your thing."
But that project, the idea
behind that project was to see
if we could kind of bring
the fields together,
'cause they kind of want to be together,
but they kind of don't
know how to be together.
A lot of people misunderstand
what AI is and what it can do,
and what it can't do.
And a lot of people misunderstand
what composition is,
what it can do, what it can't do.
But I have found it's
actually a lot harder to get
those two fields talking to each other,
because still the purposes are at odds.
But there are places where they overlap.
And so, I think that's the
direction we'll probably go
with that project that we're developing.
It's a little bit in suspense
because the original idea
we had turned out, testing the systems,
turned out to be quite complicated.
But the pieces that came
out of it were really fun.
So what David did was he
input a bunch of his work
and then got the ideas
that the program gave him
and made those into something.
So he started the piece
that he wrote for me
with the AIs ideas.
He started it with his
melody and overlapped.
So, he put an AI note in
between each of his notes.
So at first, it's the
thing that he put in.
And then he starts alternating.
So it's not him collaborating with,
it's them having a similar source,
but kind of parallel making art.
And then it ends with just the
notes that the AI was doing.
So I think that's a really great idea,
and that's something that is very David.
It's very David Lang, and he's
a very open-minded composer.
And in fact, he was one
taking it back full circle
to what we were talking
about with the 27 Encores.
He was one of the first
composers who was super on board
with the idea of having everyone
together on that project.
He's a very inclusive community builder
among all of the composition
representatives these days.
'Cause he does (indistinct)
and all these other projects.
It was really nice to find
people who would be on board
with this experiment, who
would struggle with it
and make something really
interesting out of it.
Does that answer the question?
- [Student] Yeah.
- Okay.
- [Student] And also, where is this going?
- I dunno.
(audience laughing)
- That's where we currently are.
I think people want projects
to have a clear goal,
but sometimes the point is
exploring, where can the goal be?
- So, I'm afraid we are
actually out of time.
So, can you please all join
me in thanking Hilary Hahn.
(audience applauding)
(bright instrumental music)